Film props and costumes really help make a
film feel alive.
Every little detail we see on screen has been
carefully curated by the director and the
production team to fit the aesthetic of the
production.
Sometimes however, they sneak something into
the background that may cause you to pause
and ponder if you had seen it before.
Whether due to budget restrictions or having
some fun on set, here are 10 movies that recycled
props and costumes from other movies
Marvel’s The Avengers/true lies
Remember the awesome final scene in True Lies?
The 1994 James Cameron film saw Arnold Schwarzenegger
duking it out in a jet in the final scene.
Well turns out you have actually seen that
jet more recently that you realize as the
fighter jet made a brief appearance in the
background of 2012’s The Avengers, during
the scene where Hulk and Thor have their epic
fight.
Joss Wheadon revealed his tidbit on the blu
ray commentary of avengers.
Terminator 2/predator
A double dose of classic Arnold is never a
bad thing.
But you may have thought to yourself “have
I seen that before” when it comes to the
T-800’s mini gun from T2?
In the scene, John Conner tells the terminator
not to kill anyone, resulting in fiery chaos
that spared all those police offers.
The same can’t be said of the same gun in
the predator, the 1987 alien film also starring
Arnold.
In that film, Bill Duke’s Mac sports the
same mini gun as that Arnie would use a few
years later.
Spiderman/army of darkness, evil dead, evil
dead 2, darkman/drag me to hell
Sam Raimi has a knack for reusing the same
prop in all his films.
Can you guess what it is?
Turns out, the yellow oldsmobile that Uncle
Ben was driving in Spider Man is actually
Sam Raimi’s own car, a 1973 oldsmobile delta
88.
Nicknamed “the classic”, Raimi has used
this prop in all his films, including his
evil dead franchise, darkman and drag me to
hell.
Starship troopers/Firefly/planet of the apes
Soon to be remade, Starship troopers is a
cult classic science fiction film that sees
humanity rally together to fight the bugs,
terrifying insectoid aliens hell bent on destroying
us humans.
In order to combat such a threat, humanity
wore some pretty nifty armor.
They’re so nifty in fact that you may have
wondered where else you saw them.
Chances are it was when you last binged Joss
Wheadon’s excellent Firely series, where
the Alliance soldiers used the same exact
armor as seen in Starship troopers.
The armor was also briefly used a year earlier
in the 2001 reboot of Planet of the Apes.
Evil dead 2/ Nightmare on Elm Street
A fun piece of double trivia, keen eyed fans
of 1984 Nightmare on Elm Street may have noticed
that the horror classic Evil Dead was playing
on Nancy’s TV set.
Flash-forward to 1987 and director Sam Raimi
conjured up Evil Dead 2, the campier entry
in the series.
Knowing that his film was shown in Wes Craven’s
slasher classic, Raimi decided to subtly place
the original Freddy Kruger’s glove above
the shed door before Bruce Campbell’s does
some damage with his signature chainsaw.
Raiders of the lost ark/the majestic/spy kids
Raiders of the lost ark has some of the most
famous and most celebrated moments in cinema.
One of them comes early on when Harrison Ford’s
Indiana Jones takes the golden idol off the
pedestal in the temple.
Jump ahead more than twenty years and the
idol has been rediscovered in the film within
a film, Sand Pirates of the Sahara, which
was part of the 2001 film The Majestic.
The golden figure can also be seen in an episode
of Star Trek Deep Space Nine as well as Spy
Kids 2.
A New Hope/The Empire Strikes Back
A well-hidden prop in the original Star Wars
film actually became a character in its sequel,
The Empire Strikes Back.
In the cantina in A New Hope, large metallic
drink dispensers can be seen behind the counter,
completely blending the background and not
making any sort of impression for the audience.
That is until the sequel, when those metallic
canisters would become the head for the bounty
hunter, IG 88.
The hunter would become a fan favourite in
the former Expanded Universe.
Sin City/Kill Bill Vol. 1
That really was a Hattori Hanzo sword.
That may have been what crossed your mind
when you watched 2005’s Sin City and noticed
some familiar props in the “big fat kill”
chapter.
In it, Devon Aoki plays Miho, a deadly silent
assassin who favours blades as a means to
terminate her foes.
But her coveted samurai swords actually had
their debut in another film two years earlier.
After filming the Kill Bill films, director
Quentin Tarantino stashed swords used by the
Crazy 88 in his garage, only to be used by
his buddy Robert Rodriguez shortly after.
On the Sin City commentary, Rodriguez even
stated that in the film’s cinematic universe,
Hanzo did indeed craft Miho’s swords as
well.
Forbidden planet/gremlins/invisible boy/earth
girls are easy/ tv’s the twilight zone/tv’s
lost in space/adams family/big bang theory
If you’ve seen Forbidden Planet, then you
know Robby the Robot was the standout from
that film.
So much so that he has in fact made his way
into other films as the prop was passed between
productions over the years.
The prop has appeared in dozens of productions,
including Earth Girls are Easy, Invisible
Boy, the TV shows Twilight Zone and Lost in
Space and the Adams Family as well as randomly
showing up in Gremlins.
He most recently made an appearance in season
8 of the Big Band Theory.
Star Wars 4-6/Rogue One
Gareth Edwards’ Rogue One: A Star Wars story
takes place shortly before the events of Episode
4, A New Hope.
So in keeping with the spirit of the original
trilogy, costume designer David Crossman stated
that some of the costumes in Rogue One are
in fact the same costumes that were used in
the original trilogy.
That’s our picks for 10 movies that recycled
props and costumes from other movies.
Did you notice these often hidden and reused
props and costumes before?
Which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comment section below and
don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more great videos like this one!